this is the best computer that you can
buy on Earth for five specific reasons
and it completes Steve Jobs plan on
having a powerful small computer that is
silent and can do anything that you want
it too now we have been testing and
using this for just over a month and it
is a way better computer than the
previous Mac Studio I'm not talking
about a little upgrade it is a big big
Improvement when Apple released the
original Mac Studio with the studio
display last year people were intrigued
but also a little bit confused news
because we were waiting for a new Apple
silicon Mac Pro and just a year later
they updated this but at the same time
released a new Mac Pro which really is
redundant and unnecessary for 99.9 of
people now that computer was powerful
but we had major issues especially with
the M1 Ultra version where the
performance just did not scale properly
and it made that four thousand dollar
one and especially the 5 800 spec just
not make any sense and then when they
released the new Mac mini people kind of
flocked to that as a cheaper great
option with excellent CPU performance
beating the Mac Studio but now with this
thing even the two thousand dollar spec
it literally replaces all other Macs for
the desktop now we made videos about the
M2 Chip being a stopgap chip basically
an overclocked version of the M1 then
that is technically true and we thought
that the M2 Max and M2 Ultra in this
also won't be that great but what blew
my mind is where the M2 Max was beating
out the M1 Ultra for two thousand
dollars you get a computer that nobody
else can match especially in the form
factor and how cool and Silent it runs
not sure you can make a custom PC you
can build it yourself but by the time
you buy all the components and you buy
CPUs that match up with this performance
which yes they are out there and
Graphics it still just does not compare
with the complete package running Mac OS
that just screams with pretty much
anything that you throw at it we finally
have Wi-Fi 6E which is not only
incredibly fast with new routers but
even with older routers having much
better range and performance we also
have the updated HDMI that could support
AK 60 and 4K 240 frames per second you
have an SD card with USB type C's that
are fast on the front you get the best
in the world web browsing and web
application performance and you get a
media engine that destroys even the most
expensive RTX graphics cards both in
regular codecs and prores support both
decoder and encoder that nothing else
can even touch I spoke about the two
thousand dollar afterburner card I
bought for my fifteen thousand dollar
Mac Pro and even the M2 Max costing the
same as just that card absolutely
annihilates it now what really shocked
me is when I compare the M2 Ultra in the
Max studio to the new Mac Pro which I
purchased thinking that that's the
computer we're gonna keep for a long
time for our main video editing computer
and there we saw pretty much no
differences and even as far as cooling
where the three massive fans on the Mac
Pro that I thought would do way better
well they were basically the same or
even slightly worse than this Mac
Studios cooling solution I threw
everything I could the toughest test and
it performed so well that the Mac Pro
just did not make sense and then I
compared it to my Intel Mac Pro that
cost so much money and it absolutely
embarrassed it and pretty much every
single way especially in the tougher
test and to be honest the computer that
I thought we would not be keeping is the
one that we ended up getting and the M2
Ultra this year does make sense
especially if you're somebody that
pushes the system in terms of graphics
performance for example in blender or in
terms of video editing is just so fast
just even in hardcore raw tests that
don't use the media encoders because of
this for most people even Windows users
they can pick up one of these already
pre-made and it will outperform a ton of
the competition even custom built PCS in
most categories now there are still some
limitations and some issues with the M2
Max and M2 Ultra Max Studios first off
if you're somebody that does 3D work
well in a blender or other applications
because there is no Hardware Ray tracing
well it will not do as well in those
tasks but for almost everything else
including coding even with After Effects
DaVinci Resolve photo editing in the
real world it will outperform similar
price PCS even if the benchmarks don't
perfectly align in those synthetic kinds
of tests now I think my biggest issue
with this generation is is the fact that
Apple has limited SSD speed on the base
model where the speed is pretty much
half of what it was last year and I
think this sucks on computers that are
this expensive at two thousand dollars
but on the positive side for 200 bucks
more you can jump up to one terabyte and
then the speed is back and I think at a
two thousand dollar price point it's not
as painful as on for example an M2
MacBook Air where that jump is a much
higher percentage of the actual you know
purchase price the amount of money that
you are spending it's crazy to think
that after so many failures from Apple
trying to make a small compact powerful
computer like that G4 Cube and then the
trash can that just flat out would not
work out they created product that they
were not marketing as a powerful
computer like the 2013 Mac Pro but it
turns out to be exactly what they want
wanted to do for so many years ultimate
insane performance while being cool and
silent and what really impressed me also
is the fact that the M2 Max M2 Ultra
even having way more performance in the
last generation the power usage is also
very very low sometimes actually less
now which one would I recommend for most
people well if you don't need ultimate
graphics performance I think that for 2
000 bucks the amount of performance that
you get is going to destroy much more
expensive Max that you bought in the
past and for most people it is more than
powerful enough even for us the M2 Ultra
for most cases is overkill and we're not
going to maximize the performance that
it has for our uses but at four grand
compared to eight or fifteen thousand on
a Mac Pro it just is such a great value
that for most businesses you can still
afford to buy one of these and to use
them now I think that there's a chance
that in the future Apple might just
discontinue the Mac Pro because like the
video we made a while ago this is the
new Mac Pro and so many people that were
waiting for the Apple silicon transition
to be finished well they ended up just
buying a Mac Studio anyways and I'm so
happy that the rumors of Apple canceling
this product did not come out to be true
because it is really fantastic and I
suggest based off of a chip upgrade and
going into the future with three
nanometer chips this will get even
better so after using this for over a
month testing it out I would highly
recommend it to pretty much everybody
skip the M2 Pro Mac Mini it's skip the
Mac Pro pick up one of these and you're
going to be incredibly happy and if
you've been on the window side and
you're thinking about upgrading get one
of these from Apple they have the best
return policy go in the store and
they'll tell you the same thing try it
out if you don't like it you can send it
back but I think you're gonna absolutely
love it and it will be the best computer
that you've bought in a very very long
time so here at Max Tech we would highly
recommend this new Max studio Mac Studio
Max video if you have any questions any
specific configurations you guys can ask
down in the comment section below and
check out one of those great comparisons
right over there click the circle above
to subscribe this but Max and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
thank you